of the many films that you've been
involved in which one was your greatest
teacher whether they were good lessons
or lessons of regret they've all been
great
every film at been associated with has
taught me a lot and by the way and truth
be told probably learned more from the
films that didn't get made thinking back
on why they didn't get made what could I
have done different but the films that
got made which are the ones people know
a bit more hopefully I would say the
moth Mothman Prophecies which was
another Richard Gere film was the and
there was one moment one seminal moment
and again that was a film that that had
been shocked all over town every company
independent medium big studio all passed
on it I wasn't involved at the time the
agent shopped at the writer I hadn't
produced before I was the I actually got
to produce his first film and he came to
me and said would you read this and I
fell in love with it and his and and
then I learned it had been passed on and
I found there was one company and only
one company that hadn't seen it that was
lakeshore wonderful company so I said
you know what I will I will invest time
in this and I will take it to lakeshore
and and I knew it was that was it there
was literally one buyer in the whole
world I could sell this to so I went to
them and they read it three executives
and they called me the following Monday
morning typical Monday morning call
right brilliant story we loved the craft
it was intriguing based on a true story
oh my god fascinating a beautiful
beautiful beautiful responses from all
of them at which point one of them said
so thanks so much for sending it over
it's going to be passed only in
Hollywood and I thought that wait a
minute I'm sorry did you just say it's
going to be a pass all this all that all
that you
you know all this laudatory language and
then you're dead and there was a long
pause I knew this was it this was the
last man standing there was no other
option and that was the company I
mentioned this earlier that was the
company at the moment when I said I
respectfully pass on your pass and it
was a nervous laughter I said look of
course you can pass but based on our
relationship
and our respect for one another I would
ask before you make a final final final
decision let me just come in and talk to
you so I I went to this meeting I told
these three executives the story of my
relationship with my dad why because the
script when I read it initially was so
moving to me because the character
played by Richard Gere is so lost in
grief after his beloved young wife dies
and a lot of what the texture of it was
reminiscent to me of what I felt after
my dad's death he was my best friend and
and to me this film was a great film in
its own right and it deserved to get
made and more importantly it would be a
private Amash to my dad and so I care
deeply about it so I went into this
meeting with three people who'd read it
and said nice things about it but passed
on it and so I thought the door was open
just a little bit and I never referenced
the script I never talked about the
title I just simply told the story of my
dad I told who my dad was
I talked about our friendship and our
relationship and the love that we had
and what it was like when unexpectedly
never having sex he just passed away
what that was to my family into me and I
just spent not long 12 minutes 10
minutes telling the story at the end of
which I simply said I cannot imagine
anyone don't make her actor audience
doesn't matter who will not be moved
where why or whether we lost someone or
not where
wired to understand the tragedy and
despair of losing someone so close to
you and they huddled and they change
their mind bottom line they changed
their mind and we got to make this go
and it's a great film it wasn't as big
as pretty woman but but it was well
received in acts I become more popular
over over over the years and I'm very
proud of the film but in a way as a
learning lesson is life you know we
talked earlier about never take no for
an answer and I think what I came away
from that was if you are you know if
you're ballsy enough if you're bold and
courageous and not just it's like get
naked in public if you're willing to get
naked in public people are impressed
right because we all know about
vibration and frequency and what if
you're like you know when you're deeply
moved and you're in that very deeply
authentic place and and there's no BS we
know it it's real that's very attractive
to us and that's what we want to put on
a big screen and that's what they got
they got why this is going to move the
audience and therefore potentially be a
success and the film was successful as a
business matter
but I that's now you know it I don't
measure it in those terms I just think
how do I get a yes from these people so
I can do what I so desperately want to
do as a creative person and and the only
thing I could do is tell the truth
and it worked
you